well as you know i was
making a lot of these videos which
are basically wonder pills and
the idea behind these videos is to
blow minds put new ideas into
their heads i mean the idea is to explore
the unusual wright open up to a
new perspective  and questioning everything is
a celebration of imagination a
celebration of technology is a
celebration of our ability to
alter our perspective alter
our perception open up new worlds
for our heads in the world at the
end this expressed by our
technology in our intentions
we transform the  world every day
and from airplanes and iphones
smartphones telecommunications that
have transformed what it is to be a
human being exponential technologies that
are transforming our space of
possibilities that is what is coming that it is
impossible not to get excited when you start
to think
and  well wow pills is a
celebration of e  so and you have asked me
to do one of these one of these
rennes in spanish that is good for
all of you
and well keep watching